heute zeigen wir euch wie man in berlin
ein ticket für die u bahn die s bahn den
bus und die tram kauft was gehts
entschuldigung können sie mir sagen wo
ich ein ticket kaufen kann
dieses ticket gilt für die s-bahn die
u-bahn die tram und den bus in berlin es
gibt drei möglichkeiten ein ticket zu
kaufen am automaten in der app und in
einem kiosk
garvey kauft ein ticket am automaten
carré hat ein ticket in der bvg
abgekauft
janus kauft tickets im cast einmal
kurzstrecke bitte kann ich hier bei
ihnen ein ticket für die u bahn kaufen
guten tag ich hätte gerne ein vier
artikeln
ich hätte gerne ein ticket für den bus
ich hätte gerne ein tagesticket eine
vierer karte für die u-bahn bitte könnte
ich bitte ein kurzstreckenticket an
[Musik]
ein ticket muss man nicht nur kaufen
sondern auch abstempeln
wenn man einzige nicht abstempeln dann
ist es nicht gültig können sie mir sagen
wo ich mein ticket abstempeln muss
[Musik]
im bus und in der tram stempelt man sein
ticket tatsächlich in der bahn
beziehungsweise im bus ab in der u-bahn
und in der s-bahn stempelt man sein
ticket jedoch auf dem gleis an einem
automaten ab
[Musik]
und wie lange es ein ticket gültig jedes
ticket ist für zwei stunden gültig ein
kurzstreckenticket ist jedoch nicht so
lange gültig es gilt für drei u bahn
stationen 3 s bahnstationen sechs
stationen oder sechs stationen
man kann mit einem ticket umsteigen und
verschiedene transportmittel benutzen
man muss jedoch immer in eine richtung
fahren wenn ich zum beispiel von pankow
zum alexanderplatz fahrer und 30 minuten
später wieder zurück vom alexanderplatz
nach pankow dann brauche ich tatsächlich
zwei tickets
[Musik]
kai ist heute beim schwarzfahren
erwischt worden sei was ist passiert
ja ich bin als tourist in berlin und ich
habe mir ein tagesticket gekauft und ich
bin in die u bahn eingestiegen mit man
gültigen tagesticket und ich wollte das
abstempeln
aber ich konnte es nicht abstempeln und
dann dann sind vier leute reingekommen
und allerhand kontrolliert und mir ich
wurde ein wenig nervös und hab mir dann
überlegt du hast das doch gekauft und
dann hat man mir gesagt ich wäre schwarz
gefahren und jetzt jetzt habe ich eine
quittung bekommen und morgen muss ich zu
den berliner bvg oder erst betriebe und
muss 60 euro bezahlen und mal gucken was
sie von mir wollen
das ist ja eine schweinerei kai ja habe
ich auch so empfunden denn gestern habe
ich meinen tagestipp im bus lösen können
also es gibt einen unterschied zwischen
busfahren und u bahn fahren mit dem
tagesticket wusste ich nicht das ticket
kaufen kann wirklich kompliziert sein
wenn man in einer neuen stadt ist wenn
ihr also noch fragen habt dann schreibt
uns gerne einen kommentar und wir
beantworten ihre fragen gerne und wenn
ihr jetzt weiter deutsch lernen möchte
dann empfehlen wir euch unbedingt unsere
app siedlung auf sieht man könnt ihr
nämlich auch videos gucken aber mit
interaktiven untertiteln also anders als
über youtube ihr könnt auch die
untertitel drauf mieten könnte dort die
grammatik erfahren übersetzungen
erfahren und auch einzelne wörter zu
eurem eigenen wortschatz hinzufügen und
diese später üben probiert das mal aus
und wir sehen uns nächste woche wieder
hier bei isar germany
[Musik]